I recently completed 25 sessions of radiation treatment with 50
grads. I think that's um grads, humans have dosage, colorectal tumor, there are some side effects
like painful to pass stool, some prostate, um, pain also, uh, burning, well urination,
that well hydrated. So these are negative effects of radiation on other tissues. Now the negative,
the positive of doing radiation therapy is that where it's going to hit in the distinct dosage is
going to cause cell death. And that's what we want, we want cell death of the cancer, but where it's
going to be diffused, it's going to cause cell damage. And when they're cell damaged, then you
end up with side effects of that cell damage. So you want to do everything you can to try to heal
those cells. Um, and so in, so what do you do? So do, is it just a matter of trying to use detox,
portal calls to detox the radiation? Well, I think that is necessary and you shouldn't do that,
but you have to support the cells that were damaged. So if, so that goes cell, cell line, my cell line.
So in this case, um, how do you support cells that were damaged in the intestinal tract without,
you know, supporting growth of cells in the intestinal tract? I would say using, um,
products that you would use to help heal the gut that have low amounts of glutamine in it.
Um, things like, okay, so let me, let me just pull something up here for you so it'll help
understand this a little bit. So, so like our clear GI product, our clear GI product is, um,
the reason why I like that product is because it has, I don't know, pull it up here so you can see it.
So it does have glutamine in it, but it has, it has 1.5 grams of glutamine. I tell, this is per
table spoon, and I tell people the answer, um, that are taking this because they need to heal their
gut to only do a teaspoon at a time. So you're only getting 500 milligrams of glutamine,
which is an acceptable dose of glutamine. But it has these other things. You can find other products
on the market. Matter of fact, you might have some in your cupboard that have some of these other
things modified citrus pectin right there. It can be helpful to bind radiation, but it can also be
helpful to help heal the gut. Um, deglycerized licorice. So deglycerized licorice can be very
healing to the gut. Many products are, you, you can find on the market that just have deglycerized
licorice, DGL, it's abbreviated. That is very healing to the gut. Aloe vera extract is very healing
to the gland. Slippery, Elm, um, Marshmallow, Calamille, Okra, Cat's Claw. Well, Cat's Claw is helpful for
any bacteria in the gut. MSM is a anti-inflammatory for the gut. Cursor to the gut for the gut. So those
are the things that you would think about taking for the gut. If you don't use this product, you might
have another product that has these things that I just thought of this when this question was asked,
so I pulled it out. So also this person said they're having issues with prostate. So then you
think of prostate products that are going to help. So using the prostate supreme or our prostate
clear product would be great things to do. You need to support the systems that are damaged. So if you
had, you know, radiation to the chest with breast cancer and you're having lung issues, then you think
of corniceps, you think of our, our, our clear lung product. Things that are going to help detoxify the
lunges themselves, help heal the lung tissue themselves. So depending on what organ, what tissue is damaged,
that's what you go after is for the nutritional perspective to try to heal that.
In general, what do you recommend to heal the body? Any non-cancer cells affected with this type of
treatment? So explain that. I understand high dose vitamin C also helps. Some people suggest that raw
vegan food may not be good after such treatment. Well, this is what we've talked about before.
Multiple times. You know, you hear about this so often, like every cancer patient should go on a
raw food diet. Every cancer patient should start juicing raw vegetables and start just drinking that.
That's going to cure you. This is not true. These are just statements that maybe that would be great.
A raw food diet might be great if you're 22 years old. But if you're 44 years old,
raw food diet, I'm really difficult to digest. If you have the radiation in the
colon area and you have the history of colon cancer, therefore the radiation,
a raw food diet is going to be even more difficult because you already have compromised to the colon.
It's going to be more irritating. So I would not suggest a raw diet or juicy or anything like that.
Crooked vegetables are the way to go. I've talked about this before. When people have really damaged
guts, they go on what's called a gaps diet where you're just basically making soup and
cooking it all day long. So it's already very pre-digested and easy to drag down for your gut.
And you're drinking the broth of the soup. So your vegetable broth and some of the meat broth that
can be chicken soup or something. That is the mildest on the gut and that is really helpful to start healing.
So I would suggest radiation to the colon, raw food diet, absolutely not. A very cooked food diet,
a gaps-type diet, a soup-type diet would be the best thing for a period of time to help that heal.
So yeah, I would not suggest that. I think that would be more irritating, harder to heal,
it caused more problems.